[Applause]
this is a conversation you want a real
[ __ ] conversation
yeah you want a real [ __ ]
conversation girls aren't they're not a
lot of listeners girls are not allowed
to listen but if you are listening just
don't say you're a girl
look you this is real talk
being a hooker is what illegal in most
places correct
carrying somebody else's child as a
surrogate
is legal so
you're allowed to bear the
responsibility of [ __ ]
but you're not allowed to enjoy the
thing that puts it there
that's crazy that's crazy that's a good
point
that is the best argument in my opinion
for hooking
you could pay a [ __ ] woman
40 grand or whatever it is to carry the
baby
you just can't put the [ __ ] in there
yourself
that's crazy probably a lot cheaper if
you do it yourself too
honestly i don't know if that's baked
into the cost i don't know how that [ __ ]
works but maybe
in vitro or whatever that [ __ ] is called
in utero yeah
what is it called in utero
is probably expensive all i'm trying to
say is that's nuts that showcases how
stupid sex being illegal is it's idiotic
i never put it that way or you have to
be consistent all the way through you
cannot let other women carry your kids
that's the result of sex you might not
be putting the dick in
but you're taking the sperm out of the
dick and you're throwing it up in there
which is the whole point of [ __ ] sex
anyway
yeah then you gotta legalize sex or make
surrogates illegal
i'm trying to wrap my mind that's
hooking it's something like that's
hooking
hooking isn't about the hooker it's
about the people who are
potentially cheating or whatever my
my understanding is hooking is illegal
because of
like the black market um
surrounding it right and the sex
trafficking associated with it but if
it's legal can't you nip a lot of that
[ __ ] in the budget you can that's what
they do in a lot of these places but i
don't know if i 100 believe that
because you go to germany not like i've
been to the red whatever in germany red
light district
or whatever like that but like you see a
bunch of these like russian [ __ ] out
there and stuff like that
and you know you're not certain that
they got a pimp
but like how'd they get here you think
they filed
visa papers i think it was [ __ ]
government like it would shrink the
black market i think if it's more
regulated you know it shrinks the black
market but you know what also it does
it shrinks the price these pimps hold up
the value of [ __ ] it's like diamonds
if once everybody knows diamonds is just
out there and easy to get
worth nothing is it cheaper in amsterdam
to [ __ ] cookers than it is
it's like 20 to get your dick suck like
or like 50 it's like nothing
it's like why if you just want your dick
suck you would go out to a bar and like
try to meet a girl and then hook up with
her
when you could just go get your dick
sucked by the exact proportion girl that
you would want to get stuck by
is beyond me it's like mind-boggling
like if in amsterdam
if you hook up with a girl it should be
because you genuinely are enjoying
hanging out with her it's like a fun
night and you like are vibing together
heavy
not like one of those things where it's
like 4 am like all right which
lizard is left in this [ __ ] yo so if
you make
looking legal a lot of these women won't
go on these shitty ass dates with dudes
who [ __ ] them and don't call them back
you'll have a better experience with men
as a woman who's not alone oh my god if
it's legal
because so many guys right now just want
to [ __ ] you and leave and that's it
bust a nut and be out and you have a
problem with that if hooking is legal
i busted out in this girl i don't have
to waste your time son that is a [ __ ]
brilliant way of looking at it
all these girls that are upset that they
got one night standed
that one night standing gets
compartmentalized into the hookers
into a business into a business
these hookers yup now hopefully they
don't have these pimps so they're making
the money themselves they do whatever
the [ __ ] they want with the money who
gives a [ __ ]
but at least these ladies they're
actually looking for a relationship
aren't getting one night stand at the
same level
that's my dream yo al would you be able
to remove your uh prejudice
against sex workers in order to have sex
with them instead of having one night
stand i know you have a prejudice
against sex workers
you still cannot do it who's the most
beautiful woman you've ever seen in your
entire life
outside of your mother so you wouldn't
[ __ ] your mom
outside outside of that
i just don't want to it's not that
serious like sex ain't that seriously
ow uh i want you to stop
i've been on the road with you and
you've gone multiple nights without
sleeping so that you could have sex
that is 100 facts it is 100 facts
yes it is multiple nights sleeping i've
watched you
i believe i've watched him on stage
be asleep while he's holding the camera
i've watched him as i'm on stage i've
looked at him
and he's asleep like this while he's
supposed to be filming the show
okay
i don't take midday naps no i don't
i do sometimes but that has to do with
that has to do with me being tired from
the flight on friday
not chasing posse all night long like
you
used to chase be honest you used to
[ __ ] chase back in the day
you used to chase you liked a [ __ ]
chase al
think of how much more productive you
would be if you just if you were single
and you just paid [ __ ] oh yeah it is
an
investment it is an investment into your
productivity it will bleed into every
other aspect of your life now mark
you're very serious when it comes to
that abortion
sex with these um you're very serious
when it comes to active
sex okay you take it very seriously
would you engage in prostitution ever if
you were single
if you were single hypothetically i
don't know
hypothetically you didn't invite me to
your wedding and then god made you
single because that's what would happen
hypothetically right hypothetically yeah
so he smiles my marriage and then what
yeah and you'll be single and then do i
get would you be with a
hooker well it's twofold
i don't want to i don't think i would
ethically want to but i do think i could
get broken down into doing something i
didn't want to do
why would you not want to i think it's
like
if prostitution is legal i have no
problem with it no it feels because
she's empowered to do it
yeah this [ __ ] is incorporated you know
i mean like she got a llc
my [ __ ] llc or whatever she's writing
off the wet wipes
a it's a business yeah i don't know the
stigma is removed because right now
much higher chances a sex worker it's
you she got a pimp that's probably
taking all her money off the top
if she is an empowered woman who is
making money on sex
legally i think my guilt would be pretty
much gone getting
getting oh because your guilt is wrapped
into the treatment
that she's getting yeah she's probably
not empowered she probably grew up in
some broken ass [ __ ]
and she might she's still gonna be
broken she might
now it's like having sex with a porn
star as opposed to having sex with a
hooker
yeah but they're just as broken that's
what i'm saying but you don't most
would you [ __ ] a porn star for free for
free
no money i've had sex with girls for
money
one girl for money i paid money
yeah no i have not been paid um
it's not as good
as a job yeah i think i told you guys
this
i feel like i bet if you break it down
there's a lot of times
you have sex with a girl and it's just
like all right i just gotta do this
this guy i don't see the distinction
would you be cool if a guy fingered your
girl
zero [ __ ] a professional
fingered your girl zero [ __ ] what about
the gynecologist
hey well that [ __ ] better be medical in
the [ __ ] if if there's any
insertion where there is there doesn't
need to be insertion
that's a problem
so there's the distinction yep if if a
girl is getting a rub-a-tug she's
getting finger blasted
it's going to be an issue but if your
gynecologist is deep up in there getting
a swab
it's totally okay
[Music]
so you don't want your girl to have joy
i also don't want her to be happy
without me same thing same to same
i wonder if i'd be okay if she just got
blasted
but it was like completely part of the
thing you know
a massage procedure like if a girl
gave my girl a massage and then also
added a blast
at the end yeah
you would be cool with that yeah would
you be cool with that it's different
then
i would definitely allow a girl to go
blast for a blast on my girl dude
[ __ ] can i watch yeah i'm not cool it's
different but i'm not i'm still not cool
you'd be
you'd be what intimidated or something
nah i'd be like yo
i'd be i'd feel disrespected what are
you doing why no she asked your
permission she's like can i get this
girl to finish me off so i can feel an
orgasm
once no no you ain't never feeling that
[ __ ]
never in your life i know what good sex
is like ever i also remember hearing
this [ __ ] in college though when it
comes to like prostitution
and i just looked it up again to see
what the deal is but apparently in
places where prostitutions legalize sex
trafficking actually increases
where prostitution is legal yeah sex
yeah because more people are going there
for the sex drive yeah and it's like
becomes more of a commodity and then
yeah like there's more last website you
read that on no i believe it dude
when you're in amsterdam you feel that
[ __ ] yeah like it feels seedy
oh the red light district felt mad
i don't remember when we had the video
camera out and dude ran out of nowhere
yeah
and caught it what are you doing
videotaping over here yeah yeah yeah
it's a weird ass accent like south
african or some [ __ ]
i don't think that that's the reason i
think probably prostitution is legal for
like
uh like moral like
like a puritanicalism like americans
being like oh we're a christian country
we don't do prostitution
but i apparently according to the
studies like if it's legal
more prostitution is only legal in
certain places so it's actually kind of
like a tourist thing
so do you think maybe the demand in
those places goes way up beyond supply
because it is a destination for
prostitution whereas if it's
legalized globally now there's not as
much demand we don't got to traffic in
[ __ ] it's legal everywhere
so amsterdam
there's a big drug trade there outside
of what is legal
because you're already smoking weed and
[ __ ] you're like [ __ ] i might as well
do some molly i might as well do some
coke i might
because you're going there to party and
it's rare that [ __ ] are going
there
just to smoke weed nothing else so by
making this drug legal
you've actually increased criminality
right because all these other characters
are coming in to supply the people who
want stuff along with the weed
right and i think that's what you're
saying with the globally legal
if it's legal everywhere i'm i don't
need to go to amsterdam do all these
drugs i'll do whatever i want to
i'm just trying to say that surrogate
[ __ ] yeah
i also i feel some type of way like even
if it's like a relationship if some
girl's like oh yeah you want her to [ __ ]
like it [ __ ] with my head where i'm
like what like why do you
think that yeah you've got to hang up
with this
i do not understand you're going to tell
him by yourself with that one no i know
like you need too much of like an
emotional connection kind of but i think
prostitution is just even a farther
extension of that so that's why i never
even
yeah but the thing is you've never
gotten ahead from a girl who's had a
horrible childhood
the best yeah i know and i do think it
would be great
i'm not denying it but i also recognize
like oh man i'm benefiting off like
have you ever had the soul sucked out of
your body
so i don't know yeah
i mean you're benefiting awesome trauma
either way yeah
this iphone will blow you but yeah
that's true dude
it's a real thing bro see some cuts on
her arms you're like oh it's about to be
serious
yes the answer to your pain is right in
there
they're gonna cut this whole clip and
make look what [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was about to add to it in my head i'm
like you know they're gonna do that [ __ ]
but whatever it is what it is
it is what it is ladies if you want to
learn how to give ahead
who you go to your friend who's got a
great relationship with her father
or the one that never met her
be honest ladies now you want to learn
how to suck dick
which one of your friends you asking
which one
the one that got natural nails with no
color
or the ones that got the thick acrylic
ones that look like
cheetos no fritos
you know fritos they got a lot of turn
and they come out they almost like arch
in yeah
yeah you going to her french manicure
they got about a centimeter of like the
old nail showing because she hasn't done
them
recently i'm trusting you i don't know
but i'm trusting you
that's the one yes that's the one